the only person that can stop me is the
man upstairs if he through hell through
whatever says Hey listen a little too
much go relax okay you've done your part
we don't need you anymore
salute I'm good has God always played a
big role in your life the moment I
figured out he was playing a big role in
my life yes when I was 25 years old
an atheist for 25 years they don't
believe in God my parents got a divorce
I lived in Iran I sought a bomb and I
don't trust anybody when you come out of
the Middle East you typically if you
know Middle Easterns they don't trust
people that is yeah so you know we don't
trust you know anybody it's it's very
marred underneath the very very hard
until we fully trust and even when we
fully do fully to us is 90 yeah yeah
yeah we're always we're always looking
for yeah yeah to see oh did you see what
happened did you see this like it's a
little unfair to the other nuances yes
little nuances but uh you know so so
that part for me is like you want me to
trust the pastor do you know what I saw
a pastor do you know what I saw this
person do you know what I saw this in
him no I'm good man I'm totally good
there's a bunch of fake stuff and all
these other things and then I would say
whatever yeah and I was in the Army and
one day a drill sergeant Pearl comes out
which we reconnected on social media he
comes in and says hey but David this
this that you guys can go and hang out
with this guy this camp for three days
look how great to get away from this for
three days is fantastic so we go to the
places got one of these ropes that you
go into the lake he's got a small pool
table which is great it wasn't a good
one but still was enough that we can
play but every night we have to listen
to Bible study for one hour
so he would do the Bible so I'm sitting
all the way in the back I'm not paying
attention I'm bored out of my mind I'm
just saying stuff on my mind out of your
full of you're this you're that at
the end of it the 70 year old man gives
me this Bible he says my parents gave
this to me on Christmas of 1974. this is
1997. he says son I think you need this
more than I need this I'm gonna gift you
this one my parents gave me wow and I'm
like I'm telling you I'm the wrong
person to give this to don't do this to
yourself it means more to you than me it
says I'm telling you God told me to give
it to you I'm looking till today I have
this Bible and a gift to him December
24th of 19 uh 74 whatever the year was
25 years prior to that
um
now my God this is so weird Here We Go
Again anyways that day I go back to the
barracks I'm like you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna stop praying three
times a day two God I don't believe in
so this is my prayer how it started 97
September
uh listen man I don't believe you exist
but God if you do I'm gonna talk to you
this is the only way I know how to pray
here's what my day was like my concern
is this my fear is this my insecurity is
this if you're there help me deal with
this anyways amen three times that I
prayed like that okay
so then this goes and then I get out and
then I have that one event with my mom
one day when she calls me uh uh out of
the blue at 2 30 in the morning 30
minutes after I broke up with my
girlfriend and we're in a bad situation
I'm a dead 49 000 I'm sitting My
Expedition nothing's going right I'm
about to re-enlist back into the army
I'm at the lowest point of my life and I
tell God I want to hear from my mom and
my phone rings from a block number at a
new next telephone number
818-968-66-6660 which she doesn't have
the number and I pick up I'm like what
are you doing she's Christ and I you
know I felt like my son needed I said
how'd you get my number that day I'm
like something's going on here anyways
long story short uh from that moment I
knew the uh there was a relationship and
then I went and uh went to church I
found Shepherd the rest is history and
from that moment until today uh it's
like knowing a big Authority or powerful
person has your back uh but yeah faith
has played a very important role in my
life since then
foreign